Gerissene oder gesprungene smartphone displays neben schwächelnden akkus wohl das größte problem aller handy besitzer und besitzerinnen die spider
einer der absolut beliebtesten appstore vielleicht nicht mehr lange denn eine
forschungsgruppe aus japan hat eine
Unglaubliche entdeckung gemacht ein material für displays dass sich selbst repariert wenn es gesprungen ist und haltet euch fest um das hinzubekommen
müsste man demnach in zukunft nur noch achtung
handauflegen wie das genau funktionieren soll und warum das nicht nur für jeden smartphone besitzer ein highlight wäre
Sondern auch für die umwelt jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja fantastisch sensationell
sich wahnsinnig
unglaublich unfasslich zehn jahre clixoom wer hätte das gedacht
Wir feiern dieses jahr mehr demnächst manchmal sind ja die entdeckung die durch zufall gemacht werden die besten post sind zum beispiel
Eine solche zufalls erfindungen auch in dieser fall hier könnte so einer sein ein forschungsteam aus tokio hatte nämlich eigentlich nur das ziel
Einen neuen klebstoff zu testen dabei herausgekommen ist allerdings eine neuartige polymer verbindung und die hat es in sich polymere auch
makromoleküle genannt sind chemische verbindungen die aus vielen gleichen oder ähnlichen
grundbausteinen den monomeren aufgebaut sind konkret geht es in diesem fall um
Politikers ich hoffe ich habe es richtig ausgesprochen wie die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler das neuartige material nennen es basiert also auf dem polymer
politiker an stoffen ist glas artig und hart doch wenn die polymer verbindung doch einmal splittern oder brechen sollte
Ließe sich das wohl durch den druck einer menschlichen hand reparieren wie soll das bitte
Funktionieren es handelt sich bei dem material um sogenannte selbst heilendes material und dies ist schon der erste
Baum moment denn ihre polymer verbindung ist wohl das erste selbst seine material überhaupt dass sowohl eine
Hohe mechanische stabilität als auch die fähigkeit zur selbstheilung hat und das bei
Raumtemperatur so schreiben es tabu sei da und sein team von der universität
Tokio und ihrer studie, um risse wieder zu schließen und sich selbst zu reparieren brauchen die meisten der bislang selbstheilende materialien sehr hohe temperatur
120 grad celsius oder mehr ein smartphone
Im backofen oder der mikrowelle solch eine temperatur würde andere komponenten des smartphones mit
Hoher wahrscheinlichkeit zerstören und in der mikrowelle passiert ja auch noch vieles anderes das gibt ein nettes feuerwerk anlass allerdings bei der neu
entdeckten polymer verbindung nach angaben des japanischen forschungsteams haften die geschnittenen kanten
des polymers zusammen wenn das material von menschlicher hand bei etwa 21 grad celsius
zusammengepresst wird so bildet es wieder eine feste oberfläche ohne risse und sprünge und würde demnach nach einigen und sogar seine
ursprüngliche stabilität
zurückgehalten
Der japanische doktorand juliana gisa war hat japanischen medien erzählt dass
er seine ergebnisse zuerst selbst überhaupt nicht glauben konnte bis er dann durch viele wiederholungen seines experiments das sensationelle ergebnis
Bestätigen konnte jetzt ist yanagida war optimistisch dass er mit dieser empfindung auch der umwelt etwas gutes tun kann
zitat ich hoffe dass dieses selbstheilende material nicht
So schnell weggeworfen wird wenn es einmal zerbrochen ist nicht nur die smartphone produktion und langlebigkeit könnte diese erfindung
revolutionieren sondern auch die von anderen gadgets es ist übrigens nicht das erste mal dass ein polymer
Verbindung als selbst teilen des materials smartphone displays vorgeschlagen wird verschiedene forschungsgruppen
weltweit
experimentieren daran und tatsächlich wurden auch bereits handys
Produziert die in kleinem maßstab dazu in der lage sind winzige kratzer von alleine wieder zu schließen ja wenn ihr kein video zum thema
Und auch, zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier kein abo aufs auge und vergessen dich den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken die
Smartphones der zukunft ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran